Moldau ist nicht allein das ist das
Motto des europa-gipfels von 47 Staats-
und Regierungschefs in dem kleinen Land
ein Treffen auch um zu zeigen die
Ukraine ist nicht allein denn der Krieg
fordert weiter
Opfer hier führt in diesen Tagen wieder
heftig bombardiert dazu sorgen Meldungen
über Drohnenangriffe auf Moskau für
Irritationen ein Waffenstillstand oder
eine diplomatische Annäherung in diesem
Krieg die ist in Wald der ist in weiter
Ferne Präsident selensky wirbt weiter um
Aufnahme in NATO und EU Drohnen über
Moskau Raketen auf Kiew was muss der
Westen tun unser Thema heute in der
Phönix Runde
[Musik]
ja herzlich willkommen aus Berlin mit
diesen Gästen ich freue mich dass
Wolfgang Thiersee bei uns ist von der
SPD Bundestagspräsident ade er hat ein
Appell unterzeichnet mit vielen anderen
für mehr diplomatische Bemühungen
ich begrüße Rebecca Barth sie ist höher
von Korrespondentin der ARD in der
Ukraine in Kiew und lebte aber auch
schon vor dem Krieg in Kiew vieles lange
Jahre gustav kressel ist bei uns
Militärexperte vom European counsel und
VN relations und ich begrüße Moritz
Gartmann freier Journalist ehemaliger
Chefreporter von Cicero und er war in
Russland Korrespondent einige Jahre und
hat auch aus der Ukraine berichtet er
Tiere jetzt haben wir dieses Treffen der
europäischen politischen Gemeinschaft
also als großes Zeichen auch ganz nah an
der Grenze zur Ukraine die haben auch
das Außenminister Treffen der NATO also
ein starkes Zeichen des Westens
gegenüber putin ist das ein Treffen
wodurch die Chance auf diplomatische
Lösungen erhöht wird das kann ich nicht
beurteilen trotzdem ist sind diese
Treffen sinnvoll und diese auch
kraftvollen Zeichen der Solidarität mit
der Ukraine denn es wird kein Ende
dieses Krieges geben wenn Putin nicht
ist einsieht dass er diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen kann und dafür ist die
dauerhafte und stabile auch militärische
aber nicht nur militärische Solidarität
mit der Ukraine eine Voraussetzung das
heißt aber sie sagen schon es muss
weiter militärisch unterstützt werden
bei voller militärischen Solidarität
geht es nur darum ob man auch noch und
deswegen habe ich diesen Appell
unterschrieben ob man im Krieg bei
voller militärischen Solidarität über
den Krieg hinaus denken kann und darüber
denken an wie kann man ihn beenden denn
nur durch Krieg alleine weiß ich nicht
ob er beendbar ist keiner kann
definieren was ein Sieg über Putin
Russland ist wann er eingetreten ist
weil das so schwierig ist es sinnvoll in
in der Zeit der militärischen
Auseinandersetzung auch nach Wegen zu
suchen wie man aus ihm wieder
herauskommt
bleiben wir aber im Moment noch mal bei
der militärischen Auseinandersetzungen
Dressel die Drohnen auf Moskau haben
irgendwie alle irritierter wenn man
nicht ganz klar ist woher sie nun kommen
und was das bedeutet was können Sie uns
dazu sagen wer sie kommen heute
wahrscheinlich auch so Ukraine also zwei
Muster ja schon identifiziert an Drohnen
das sind aufklärungsdrohnen die
eigentlich vor dem Krieg in Ukraine
entwickelt wurden die jetzt in dieser
Rolle eigentlich nicht mehr einsetzbar
sind weil sie über dem Kampfgebiet eine
relativ kurz Überlebensdauer hätten
was das Ziel der Angriffe war ob sie
überhaupt Angriffe waren oder ob sie
Aufklärungsmissionen geflogen haben zum
Austesten etwa der Flieger wäre muss
Moskau das ist zum gegenwärtigen
Zeitpunkt noch nicht klar die Angaben
sind da sehr widersprüchlich es gibt
auch zu wenig belastbare Fotos über die
die wirklichen Ziele also man kann
darüber spekulieren wo sie hingeflogen
hätten es sind die meisten ja
abgeschossen worden bevor Sie mögliche
Ziele erreicht haben indem sie in würde
ich sagen in erster Linie ein
Ablenkungsmanöver dass sozusagen der der
politischen Vorführung Putins in Moskau
dient und zu zeigen also die bewusst
Gebiete überflogen in denen sozusagen
die Nummer
wohnt man kann hier auch diesen diesen
Luftraum biegen
darüber hinaus wird kann man im Grunde
nur spekulieren
sie kennen sich gut aus auch in Russland
was bedeutet das oder was was denken Sie
was das für eine Wirkung hat diese
Drohnen
ich glaube es gibt unterschiedliche
Auswirkungen zum einen ich habe mich mit
verschiedenen bekannten Freunden dort
unterhalten zum einen ist es natürlich
ein Schock für die Moskauer weil sie
diesen Krieg bisher schon sehr gut
ausblenden konnten moskau ist nicht der
Ort wo die Leute angeworben werden für
diesen Krieg sondern die kommen hier aus
der Provinz das heißt Moskau die Regale
sind voll man konnte diesen Blick äh
diesen Krieg hält gut ausblenden man
konnte da Yoga im Gorki Park machen und
so weiter und plötzlich kommen da
Drohnen an über Moskau werden
abgeschossen war aber es ist natürlich
ein Zeichen dass dieser Krieg plötzlich
sehr präsent ist
andererseits muss man sagen man kann
sich gewissermaßen darüber freuen ja man
kann sagen endlich müssen die Moskauer
auch erstmal auch noch mal erleben wie
es ist so
von Raketen oder Drohnen angegriffen zu
werden das was die Ukraine seit 15
Monaten erleben andererseits kann man
natürlich auch annehmen dass das dadurch
die Geschlossenheit der Russen oder der
Moskauer noch stärker Weg wächst weil
sie direkt angegriffen werden meinten
wir erinnern uns leider an das Dritte
Reich als die Alliierten über Jahre ein
Krieg gegen Deutschland geführt haben
ein Luftkrieg deutsche Städte
bombardiert haben um den
Widerstandsgeist zu brechen und es ist
nicht gelungen bis zum Ende Deutschland
musste quasi erst ganz erobert werden
das heißt das ist auch eine mögliche
Wirkung dieser dieser Drohnen Angriffe
privat wie wird wurde das in Kiew
gesehen oder in der Ukraine diese
Angriffe ist das so ein Punkt
dann sehen die endlich auch mal wie es
uns geht oder denkt man da auch noch
das würde ich auf jeden Fall so
unterschreiben also wir haben jetzt in
diesem Fall das auf jeden Fall nicht
offensichtlich militärische Ziele
getroffen worden da gab es vorher schon
Vorfälle wo genau das in Russland
passiert ist da sind beispielsweise
Militärflughäfen
öldepots Munitionsdepots teilweise
angegriffen worden wo man sagen kann das
sind ganz klar militärische Ziele es hat
ein militärischen Zweck und damit ist es
auch von Völkerrecht gedeckt das scheint
jetzt bei dem letzten Angriff auf Moskau
nicht der Fall aber das ist eine Frage
die die Menschen in der Ukraine auch
nicht interessiert denn sie sagen wir
leben seit 15 Monaten mit Angriffen die
viel viel viel brutaler sind also einige
Drohnen auf Moskau sind kein Vergleich
zu den Angriffen die die Menschen
tagtäglich in der Ukraine erleben müssen
keinen Vergleich auch zu dem letzten
Monat den wir in Kiel vor allem erlebt
haben mit dutzenden Raketen dutzenden
Drohnen die nahezu täglich auf
verschiedenste Städte in der Ukraine
gefeiert werden die Menschen dort wach
halten die schlafen seit etwa einem
Monat nicht mehr richtig das macht die
Bevölkerung unfassbar mürbe und
dementsprechend empfinde ich oder denke
ich doch dass deine gewisse Art von
Schadenfreude dabei ist die meine ich zu
spüren wenn ich mit den Menschen in der
Ukraine spreche hat hier ist das eine
rote Linie die da überschritten wird
wenn eben jetzt die Ukraine auch Ziele
in Russland angreift also zunächst mal
hat jetzt zum Glück keine rote Linien
definiert aber trotzdem wissen wir doch
dass es eine wie ich finde erklärlich
und berechtigte Zurückhaltung des
Westens gibt selber nicht in der
Weltöffentlichkeit und Eindruck zu
machen dass es der Westen ist Europa ist
in diesem Konflikt die
eskalationstreiber sind
zugleich aber zu zeigen wenn Putin
weiter eskaliert wir halten dagegen wir
unterstützen die Ukraine immer dass sie
dagegen hält und deswegen mag man ja das
Gefühl haben das geschieht euch recht
dass er das auch mal erlebt aber
politisch gibt das auch glaube ich aus
Sicht der Ukraine keinen Sinn sozusagen
diesen Eindruck einer einer Eskalation
über die eigene Grenze hinaus zu machen
bisher hatte die Ukraine alles
moralische Recht auf ihrer Seite sie
verteidigt sich gegen einen Aggressor
der das Land überfallen hat und da hat
sie auch den Anspruch volle
Unterstützung bekommen ich habe den
Eindruck dass auch die Amerikaner eher
zögerlich sind wenn der Eindruck
entsteht dass die Ukraine sozusagen über
diese vereinbarte nicht rote Linie aber
vereinbarte Haltung nicht selber zu
eskalieren hinausgeht
ja ich würde gerne hinzufügen was die
Ukraine ja verstärkt macht in den
letzten Monaten ist sie trägt den Krieg
tatsächlich nach Russland hinein sie
greift verschiedene in verschiedenen
Städten mit Drohnen an sie es gab diese
Angriffe von russischen freiwilligen
Verbänden auf kleine Grenzorte in die
Belgrad aber die rote Linie die sie
bisher nicht überschreiten und das hat
auch seine Gründe ist dass mit
westlichen Waffen zu tun das ist glaube
ich eine auch von den westlichen
Partnern definierte rote Linie man muss
auch bei den bei den Angriffen in
Russland zwei Kategorien unterscheiden
es gab einmal diese Drohnenangriffe in
Moskau die die ihr politische Natur sind
die meisten Angriffe aber auch mit
betonen im russischen Hinterland sind in
Zusammenhang mit der Gegend Offensive zu
sehen oder mit den unmittelbaren
Kampfhandlungen also ölpos in die
richtigen aus äh die die
Achter Armee bedient wird die wir haben
einen rüstungswirtschaftlichen
Zusammenhang also das ist im Grunde
Nachschub für die für die Panzer genauso
Eisenbahnlinien die unmittelbar Reserven
hinter der russischen Front bzw hinter
auf russischem Gebiets war aber die
natürlich die
unmittelbar Fronten an Verbände bedienen
das macht alles militärisch Sinn auch
diese diese Überfälle im Grenzgebiet das
ist im Grunde will man Russland dazu
zwingen seine Südgrenze militärisch zu
sichern die ihre relativ schwach
gesichert da gibt's FSB Grenztruppen und
Bars und mobil gemacht Leute mit mit
verzweifel auf dem Kampf fährt ähnliches
hatte Russland im Frühling mit der
Ukraine gemacht dass man in Belarus
große Manöver abhielt um die Ukraine zu
zwingen ihre Nordgrenze zu sichern und
nicht alle Truppen in dornbas zu fliegen
ähnlich spielt das jetzt die Ukraine mit
Moskau durch nehmen Sie durch diese
Nadelstiche sozusagen zwingen Puppen
ausdruckreine abzuziehen aus dem
Kampfgebiet abzuziehen dort die Frauen
zu schwächen indem man diese Grenze
schützt aber jetzt natürlich nicht mit
dem sozusagen mit dem unmittel baren
Interesse sich dort Gebiete anzueignen
damit man für die Gegend Offensive für
die Befreiung von eigenen Temperaturen
jetzt wieder mehr Raum hat und das macht
eigentlich den überwiegenden Teil dieser
Operationen auf die jetzt auch natürlich
auf russischen Staatsgebiet stattfinden
aber die relativ klar Zusammenhang mit
dem haben was sonst in der Ukraine in
diesem in diesem Krieg passiert
das ist dass die Ukraine dann sozusagen
moralisch etwas verspielen
das kann ich nicht bewerten ich denke
das wird der weitere Verlauf dieses
Krieges zeigen aber ein Punkt der ja
ganz häufig auch in einer westlichen
Debatte fällt ist die Angst die Gefahr
einer weiteren Eskalation und dazu würde
ich ganz gerne auch die ukrainische
Perspektive darstellen die Menschen in
der Ukraine sehen diese Gefahr
eigentlich nicht sie haben nicht so viel
Angst wie wir hier im Westen von der
noch weiteren Eskalation denn sie sagen
wie soll das denn noch weiter eskalieren
unsere Städte werden teilweise dem
Erdboden gleich gemacht es werden Kinder
zu Tausenden offenbar deportiert
verschleppt es werden Städte ganze
Gebiete russifiziert und zwar mit Gewalt
dieses System basiert auf einem System
der Folter dass der russischen
besatzungsstruppen und das alles
erfahren die Menschen seit mindestens
anderthalb Jahren tagtäglich aber viele
auch schon seit neun Jahren in den
besetzten Gebieten im Don was und das
nehmen Sie um jetzt zu sagen wir wissen
eigentlich gar nicht aus unserer Sicht
wie soll es noch schlimmer kommen
Nuklearschlag zum Beispiel viele
Menschen in der Ukraine tatsächlich
nicht die Menschen in der Ukraine sagen
dann soll er halt
so weit ist dieser Krieg mittlerweile
eskaliert dass viele Menschen in der
Ukraine genau diese Einstellung haben
die haben davor keine Angst mehr hat
hier so wie groß ist ihre Befürchtung
vor einer Eskalation auch in Richtung
eines nuklearschlages ich kann die die
die Erlebniswelt der Ukraine ja
nachvollziehen aber es ist natürlich
auch sinnvoll eine Perspektive von außen
beizubehalten wir sind nicht in der
Ukraine sondern wir müssen sehen wie
dieser Konflikt weitergeht wir beendet
werden kann wie die Kräfteverhältnisse
in der Welt sind wer überhaupt dazu
beitragen kann dass er beendet wird und
ich meinte ja diese Welt Eskalation
Zurückhaltung des Westens hat doch auch
damit zu tun wenn ich das richtig
wahrnehme das große Teile der Welt nicht
auf der Seite des Westens sind nicht auf
der Seite der USA und dann und und und
Europas sondern sondern sollen die da
die Schlacht schlagen
deswegen sage ich ja ausdrücklich
wir müssen sehen der Westen so sehen wie
er andere Teile der Welt gewinnt dazu
einen Beitrag zu leisten dass dieser
Krieg zu Ende geht also sie wegzubringen
gewissermaßen auf der Seite Russlands
oder Chinas oder sozusagen durch
Untätigkeit oder wirtschaftliche
Beziehung doch indirekt dazu beizutragen
da ist schon nicht unwichtig wie der
Westen auch militärisch agiert und das
scheint mir diese Art von Zurückhaltung
die ja nicht nur eine europäische
deutsche oder Französisch ist sondern
auch eine US-amerikanische durchaus
sinnvoll zu sein ohne sagt das Person
ist noch einmal die militärische
Solidarität mit der Ukraine etwa zu
weinen was macht er jetzt mehr Sinn es
ist wichtiger diesen Krieg zu beenden
mit der Offensive die ja jetzt wohl seit
einiger Zeit läuft oder mit einer
bestimmten Zurückhaltung und dem ja
bemühen andere Länder mit einzubinden
also ich sehe jetzt kein anderes Land
das wirklich fähig und willenswert
Russland zu einer Einstellung des
Krieges zu bewegen auch
die chinesische Position dieser was bei
uns jetzt zwölf Punkte Plan gehandhabt
sind das sind zwölf Statement Punkte wie
China den Krieg sieht aber das ist als
kein Plan wie man zu einem Frieden kommt
in dem Sinn ist der militärische Druck
und auch die Gegenoffensive ein ein
wichtiger essentieller Teil davon den
Krieg zu beenden weil ohne eine
militärische Niederlage oder ein
herauswerfen sozusagen
ein Schlagen der russischen Truppen
Putin ja immer noch an eine
siegperspektive glaubt
so wie die Zahl die Zeilen jetzt stehen
hat
verlautern lassen und auch Putin im
Pressekonferenzen gesagt die russischen
Ziele in Ukraine sind nur militärische
erreichbar das heißt er will nicht
verhandeln wenn er sieht dass sie nicht
mehr erreichbar sind kann es sein dass
er verhandelt aber bis dahin ist es
militärisch noch ein langer Weg das
zweite Problem ist dass man glaube ich
im Westen auch unterschätzt ist das P
auf Zeit spielt er hat im Verlauf seiner
Amtszeit so viele amerikanische
Präsidenten rein und rausgehen sehen mit
politikwechseln um 180 Grad er hat
Kanzler er hat französische Präsidenten
rein und rausgehen mit jeder hat
irgendwas anderes zugetragen und er
spielt wieder dass er vielleicht mit
einer neuen Konstellation was anderes
bekommt und trägt den Krieg hinaus aber
er sieht ja jetzt wie sehr der Westen
doch einig ist ja gerade man so so
dieses Treffen jetzt von 47
europäischen Staatsangehörigen ganz nah
an der Grenze zur Ukraine also ist das
etwas was Putin irgendwie beeindrucken
kann
ich glaube
er hat natürlich am Anfang gehofft dass
der dass er den Westen spalten könnte
anhand wirtschaftlicher Argumente gerade
Deutschland als Schlüsselland ich glaube
er hat auf die deutschen gehofft dass
sie die Ukraine opfern würden dieser
Plan ist nicht aufgegangen aber das hat
er jetzt so hingenommen ich glaube nicht
dass dieser Gipfel jetzt für Putin
irgendwie einschüchtern einschüchtern
wirken könnte
ich denke er spielt auf Zeit
er glaubt immer noch sieben zu können er
glaubt dass der Westen müde wird das in
Amerika irgendwann Wahlen kommen das
vielleicht jemand ganz anderes dort an
die Macht kommt mit dem Ukraine gar
nicht mehr so relevant sein wird das
vielleicht in Frankreich jemand anderes
an die Macht kommen wird und das ist
eine große Hoffnung dass ihm diese
westlichen gesellschaftsten irgendwann
der Ukraine müde sein werden er hat bis
jetzt das Problem nicht in Russland ähm
Wirtschaft Russland das ja und
wirtschaftlich hält Russland das ein bis
zwei Jahre mindestens noch durch man hat
ja auch wenn ich keinen militärexpertin
bin doch den Eindruck dass das schon
jetzt übergegangen ist erschöpfungskrieg
von dem Putin hofft dass er den längeren
Atem hat und wir im Westen nicht wissen
ob wir ihn haben aber auch wenn wir
hoffen müssen
und ich teile die Hoffnung ausdrücklich
dass die Ukraine militärisch
erfolgreicher wird also eine Offensive
an der Front gewinnt ist damit ja Putin
noch lange nicht geschlagen oder
einsichtig dass er nicht gewinnen kann
dann das was er jetzt tut passiert ja im
Moment nicht an der Front sondern das
ist Terror gegen die Zivilbevölkerung
gegen die Infrastruktur und selbst bei
ukrainischen Siegen an der Front kann er
diese Art von Krieg immer weiterführen
ganz lange weiterführen auch das ist ein
Gründe dafür immer noch zwischendurch zu
fragen welche Möglichkeiten gibt es da
wieder rauszukommen weil ich ich glaube
nicht dass unmittelbar aus dieser
militärischen Konfrontation selber die
Friedenslösung kommen kann obwohl ich
ausdrücklich Zustimmung ohne die
militärische unterstützen oder Ukraine
und auch militärische Erfolge der
Ukraine wird es keine solche Lösung
geben aber sie selber
ich weiß nicht ob sie schon die
Voraussetzung für Friedenslösung schafft
ob da nicht zusätzliche Anstrengung und
gleichzeitiger Anstrengung notwendig
sind
genau ein paar Dinge wurden hier schon
angesprochen also zum einen jetzt haben
wir die Situation sie haben vollkommen
recht Pudding kann das immer
weitermachen
was muss getan werden die Ukraine
braucht mehr
luftverteidigungssysteme wir merken dass
in Kiew dass diese Systeme unter anderem
auch von Deutschland geliefert im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Leben retten
diese ganzen Dutzende von Raketen die ja
fast jeden zweiten Tag auf diese Stadt
geschossen werden und wir hören die ja
das sind wirklich sehr sehr laute
Explosionen die Wände zittern die
Scheiden klären und es sind unter
anderem deutsche Systeme die diese
schaffen diese Raketen runterzuholen
also dort merken wir wirklich den
direkten Effekt von diesen
Waffenlieferung das ist das eine zum
anderen wollte ich darauf hinweisen auch
der Ukraine ist bewusst dass sie auch
auf dem diplomatischen Weg sich
sozusagen ihre Partner suchen muss und
vor allem noch viele viele Länder
überzeugen muss ich finde das merken wir
schon dass ich auch die Kommunikation
die Diplomatie der Ukraine da verändert
hat denn sie wissen wir sind abhängig
von der Unterstützung es gibt selbst in
der EU-Länder die sind nicht wirklich
auf unserer Seite da gibt es Länder die
sind doch eher Russland freundlich oder
Regierungen und die Ukraine so empfinde
ich es ist sehr stark dabei aktuell
gerade diese Länder und dann den
globalen Süden wir sehen uns auch bei
China die mit oder über China
kommuniziert wird dieser harte Ton der
beispielsweise in Deutschland oft
getroffen hat noch vor einigen Monaten
den gibt es gegen China nicht obwohl es
der wichtigste Partner eigentlich
Russland ist und das ist ein Zeichen
dafür dass die Ukraine versuchen die
Länder die ihre Position sozusagen nicht
verstehen oder nicht teilen zu
überzeugen
nachhaken zum zur Frage des Sieges ist
zurzeit steht die Front noch so das
Putin in diesem Krieg Gebiete gewonnen
hat dass er unterm Strich sozusagen
teritual positiv aussteigt wir wollen
natürlich jeder der aus westlicher Sicht
die Opfer die dafür gebracht wurden und
sozusagen die trümmerwüsten anschaut die
man da erobert hat sich an den Kopf
greift und denkt der spinnt aber aus aus
der Sicht die er verkaufen kann
natürlich ist der Krieg noch ein Erfolg
das kann sich aber durchaus ändern für
Russland und die Frage ist bleibt er
immer noch so hart und nachgiebig und
hoffentlich auf den nächsten
amerikanischen Präsidenten dass der eine
Orange getönte Mann wird der in die
Ukraine vor die Füße wirft wenn der
Krieg wirklich und auch für die
sozusagen für die eigen für das
begeisterte Z Publikum kein Erfolg mehr
ist da
sehe ich schon viele Stellschrauben an
denen man militärischen drehen kann um
Russland in eine Verhandlungsposition
auch zu bringen und das tut die Ukraine
jetzt auch gerade weil er immer die
ganze Zeit gesprochen wurde von dieser
Offensive also da haben sie den Eindruck
dass die Ukraine da jetzt stärker wird
weil sie das wird sich über dem das
werden wir über dem Sommer sehen also es
gibt natürlich viele
sagen wir so noch noch
unbelastete Dinge also wir kennen zum
Beispiel Tiefe russische
Verteidigungsstellungen die ausgehoben
wurden die vorbereitet worden sind
allerdings die Leute die diese besetzen
sind mobil gemacht die Leute die zum
Teil noch nie Kampf gesehen haben das
heißt wir wissen nicht wie gut sie sich
im Endeffekt schlagen und wir sehen auch
auf der ukrainischen Seite neu
aufgestellte Brigaden das sind alte
theateralverteidigungsverbände die jetzt
mechanisiert wurden mit neuen Armen mit
neuer Ausrüstung die treten auch als
mechanisierten als mechanisierte Gruppen
dann zum ersten Mal ins Gefecht also da
kommt auch viel Neues auf uns zu wir
können uns in etwa ausrechnen dass die
Ukraine sollen etwa die Stärke hat um
eineinhalb boblaste auch gegen 10
militärischen Widerstand zurückkommen zu
erobern das ist in etwa die
Stärken Dimension die man hat aber im
Krieg ist natürlich alles immer eine
Chance man hat nie die letzte Gewissheit
dass alles gut geht auch wenn Ukraine
gute Kommandanten haben die können sich
mal ihren die können mal falsche Lage
Informationen kriegen die können mal
einen schlechten Tag haben es kann immer
vieles schief gehen für beide Parteien
unterstellen wir solche relativen
Erfolge der ukrainischen Seite
ausdrücklich
aber sie rechnen mit einer
beträchtlichen Rationalität von Putin
was mich ein bisschen wundert
das könnte ein neuer Irrtum in der
Beurteilung dieser Person sein
ist die Angst ganz falsch das wenn Putin
militärischen die Ecke gedrängt wird
wenn es nach einer richtigen Niederlage
aussieht dass er dann zur reaktionfähig
ist die wir uns alle nicht wünschen
können es ist nun mal eine super macht
und die hat verfügt über höchst
unterschiedliche Atomwaffen ich weiß
wird immer typisch deutsch die Angst von
Atomwaffen aber
der Unterschied zu
Auseinandersetzung und kalten kriegen
mit berechnet das waren vergleichsweise
rationale Persönlichkeit man konnte sie
ausrechnen und jetzt haben wir lernen
müssen dass man Putin nicht ausrechnen
kann
ich glaube er ist relativ rational ist
relativ brechenbar aber ich denke es wie
Stalin halt keine angenehmer Zeitgenosse
aber in dem was er tut und in dem in
seinem ideologischen Gebäude macht das
was er macht für ihn Sinn ja
ich sehe auch
nicht wirklich hoch aber dazu kann man
vielleicht später noch was sagen so der
Persönlichkeit Putin sie wie würden sie
es einschätzen es ist leider so dass
natürlich dass der Februar des letzten
Jahres uns gelehrt hat nicht dem
Wunschdenken zu verfallen natürlich
haben wir damals uns auch alle gewünscht
und haben auch deshalb darüber
gesprochen dass so ein großer Krieg
nicht möglich sein wird das Putin
ein vernünftiger Mensch am Ende ist und
das nicht tun wird und die Wirklichkeit
hat uns leider etwas anderes gelehrt
deswegen natürlich tendiere ich auch
dazu
das eher auszuschließen dass Putin einen
ein Atombombe einsetzen wird im Falle
wenn er in die Ecke gedrängt wird
auch weil sein wichtigster Partner China
sicherlich diese
Linie klar gezeichnet hat aber
wie gesagt das letzte Jahr lehrt uns am
Ende ist das nicht auszuschließen ich
nehme nicht auf mich zu sagen
dass das ist auszuschließen ja
eine Sache ich gebe Moritz gar keinen
vollkommen recht aber das letzte Jahr
lehrt uns eben auch die russische Armee
hat heftige Schläge erlitten die
Versenkung der Moskau Beispiel und davon
gab es einige und das waren immer
Momente die wir auch in der Ukraine
erlebt haben wo wir auch selber Angst
bekommen haben und mit großen großen
Angriffen gerechnet haben als Rache
die sind nicht gekommen
und wir hatten diese Momente schon
mehrmals das also Angst weil die Ukraine
gewissen militärischen Erfolg hatten man
Angst vor einer Eskalation hat und
diesen die sind alle nicht gekommen ich
weiß auch nicht warum ich kann nicht in
Putins Kopf gucken und ich würde auch
nicht sagen Angst vor einer atomaren
Eskalation ist vollkommen nach Homburg
um Gottes Willen dafür ist das Thema
viel viel zu sensibel und die
Konsequenzen wären viel zu schlimm aber
das ist die Denkweise der Ukraine sie
sehen sich ihre eigenen Schläge an und
sagen passiert ist eigentlich nichts und
immer kamen diese Fragen aus dem Westen
oh Gott jetzt muss er aber erst
verlieren Ich würde gerne auf den auf
den den Wunsch nach Frieden
Waffenstillstand und all das noch mal
eingehen wollen hätte in diesem Appell
steht ein Satz statt der Dominanz des
Militärs brauchen wir die Sprache der
Diplomatie und des Friedens welche
Sprache spricht denn Putin
das ist ja eine Schwäche dieses Appells
ausdrücklich ich habe ja gesagt ich
bei voller auch militärischer
Solidarität mit der Ukraine haltiges für
sinnvoll zugleich darüber nachzudenken
über Wege wie man als der militärischen
Konfirmation die da rauskommt das soll
und darf nicht verteufelt werden wie es
zunächst mal in der öffentlichen Meinung
ja passiert ist
diesen Punkt muss man ausdrücklich
machen und ich wiederhole mich und sage
Putin verstehst du zunächst mal keine
andere Sprache aber die Frage ist wie er
ja wie man selber dazu beiträgt dass er
daraus herauskommen kann
wenn man unterstellt das ist so etwas
einfach nicht gibt wie eine totale
Niederlage dieser Großmacht oder Atom
macht Russland wenn man sagt das ist
einfach nicht recht vorstellbar
militärische Niederlagen ja aber
sozusagen diese ein totaler Sieg über
wenn das nicht möglich ist wenn man sich
das nicht recht vorstellen kann und ich
habe bisher keinen gehört der das
beschreiben kann was wie das aussehen
könnte dann ist es sinnvoll zu sagen wie
kann man selber dazu beitragen dass
diese
durchaus immer nach wie vor
hochgefährlich macht aus der
militärischen Dominanz aus dem
Militär findest dann Zugeständnisse
machen
immer nur unter der Beteiligung der
Ukraine geht nicht ohne sie nicht gegen
sie nur und mit ihrer Beteiligung
das ist selbstverständlich aber dann
Ukraine hat ja Ideen tatsächlich die
Ukraine hat Ideen und die laufen im
Endeffekt letztendlich immer auf eine
eu-nation Mitgliedschaft als
Sicherheitsgarantien heraus die Ukraine
wollen vorher wissen was was können wir
fest suchen damit uns das nicht noch
einmal passiert aktuell sagt natürlich
niemand in der Ukraine wir sind bereit
Gebiets Zugeständnisse zu machen
ich gehe trotzdem davon aus dass
durchaus eine gewisse
Verhandlungsbereitschaft irgendwann
möglich wäre über den Status gewisser
Gebiete im Sinne von wir könnten diese
Frage aufschieben es gab es als der
Krieg angefangen hat hat Präsident
selenski genau diesen Vorschlag gemacht
beispielsweise die Frage der Krim können
wir erst einmal hinten anstellen was ist
passiert guter und das ist das ist eine
Eskalation in diesem Krieg die in der
öffentlichen Meinung in der Ukraine
natürlich dazu führt dass man über so
etwas überhaupt nicht redet da gibt es
aktuell keinen öffentlichen
Diskussionsraum
drüber war irgendetwas was in Richtung
Verhandlung geht ist ein absolutes No-Go
gerade in der öffentlichen Debatte in
der Ukraine das kann man verstehen aber
das kann man auch kritisieren
nichtsdestotrotz macht die Ukraine diese
Schritte aber das stellt uns wiederum
vor die Frage
NATO-Mitgliedschaft EU-Mitgliedschaft
ist das realistisch und dann an NATO
wird geschafft sind wieder die Fragen
geknüpft eskaliert das nicht vielleicht
genau das wäre nämlich jetzt genau die
Frage Herr gab mal wie würden sie es
denn
einschätzen die Ukraine ist ja aus
Gründen nicht NATO Mitglied geworden
genau weil man diese Eskalation nicht
haben wollte mit Russland wenn das jetzt
so ist beim NATO-Außenminister treffen
würde da wieder drüber gesprochen sie
Lenz gewirkt da sehr stark für wenn die
Ukraine NATO Mitglied würde EU-Mitglied
was heißt das in Richtung Russland
also silensky hat ja selber gesagt ich
glaube heute also dann gefragt wurde
wann soll das Stattfinden diese diese
Eintritt in die NATO nach dem Sieg der
Ukraine so das ist natürlich bewusst
schwammig definiert in diesem Moment
nicht was heißt der Sieg wie nah nach
dem Sieg soll der NATO-Beitritt kommen
ich glaube es gibt da relativ wenig
Spielraum
momentan
über die Frage
wann die Ukraine wirklich in die NATO
eintreten kann weil die westlichen
Partner die NATO die wichtigsten NATO
Länder in der jetzigen Situation und
auch solange dieser Konflikt mit
Russland nicht irgendwie geregelt ist
die Ukraine einfach nicht aufnehmen
werden weil sie auf jeden Fall vermeiden
wollen dass tatsächlich die NATO in
diesen Krieg mit Russland reingezogen
wird und NATO Truppen gegen Russland
kämpfen werden wie wichtig ist dass man
auf der einen Seite der Ukraine die
Sicherheitsgarantien gibt die auch
diesen diese Perspektive gibt NATO und
EU und auf der anderen Seite dann die
Gefahr dass Russland genau das wieder
als Bedrohung prinzipiell wie oft
taktischen Gründen sollte die
Perspektive auf die NATO-Mitgliedschaft
ausdrücklich offen bleiben das
prinzipiell wie auch als taktischen
Gründen jetzt etwa das auszuschließen
das ist politisch wäre politisch dumm
aber zugleich wissen wir doch auch dass
zur NATO gehört dass sie sozusagen
selber nicht in einem aktuellen Konflikt
ein erweiterungsket tun kann aber wir
wissen doch auch so sehr nüchtern es
wird kein Ende des Krieges geben ohne
Sicherheitsgarantie und das ist ja eine
wirklich wirklich wie soll man mit
irgendeine Art von Vertragswerk mit
Putin Russland machen der alle Verträge
gebrochen hat der sozusagen
europäische Friedensordnung zerstört hat
und trotzdem ist das die Herausforderung
die auf uns zukommt und das wird nicht
gehen ohne sozusagen diese von
Sicherheitsgarantien über die man
zunächst mal im Verborgenen reden muss
nicht öffentlich aber jeder weiß ist
dass es nicht ohne geht und deswegen
sage ich aus prinzipiellen sie aus
taktischen Gründen muss diese
Perspektive offen bleiben auch wenn sie
nicht eine der von diesem Jahr ist
wie könnten denn Sicherheitsgarantien
Aussehen der Kanzler hat sich da halt
mit dieser bedeckt gehalten und dann bei
der Frage danach was das dann eigentlich
heißt da gibt es verschiedene Modelle
auch die sind im Grunde seriös wirklich
nur diskutierbar wenn er kriegt mal
aus dieser aktiven Phase raus ist das
eine werden bilaterale das eine wäre mal
sozusagen die Israel Lösung dass man
keine
Garantie für die Verteidigung eines
anderen Staates hat aber dass man ihn
mit Waffenlieferungen soweit ausrüstet
dass er sich selber verteidigen kann das
wäre sozusagen eine Form der
sicherheitsfürsorge die selbst während
eines laufenden Krieges sozusagen
eingegangen werden kann
die zweite Variante wäre eine Art Taiwan
Szenario oder japanszenario so
bilaterale Verträge wie USA etwa mit mit
Japan hat oder mit Südkorea
einer Beistandspflicht da ist aus
ukrainischer Sicht natürlich die Sache
die dass man weiß die Volatilität
amerikanische Außenpolitik ist um vieles
höher als jetzt in den
1950er Jahren war bzw
in den 70er Jahren also in die die
entsprechenden Abmachungen mit Taiwan
getroffen wurden und das natürlich ein
ein Vertrag wo äh oder eine Organisation
in der 31 Staaten Mitglied sind wo auch
falsch einmal ein Präsident auf Abwegen
rutscht dann eben auch die 30 anderen
Staaten dafür eintreten dass die USA
auch wirklich bei den commitments bleibt
eine höhere Versicherung sind also ein
bilateraler Vertrag deshalb
aber es ist sozusagen im Falle wir sehen
das ja auch mit Schweden und Finnland im
Falle etwa der Uneinigkeit des
Bündnisses das ist ja ganz unabhängig
davon wie sich der Krieg und wie sich
Russland und wie sich die Ukraine
entwickelt die Uneinigkeit des
Bündnisses mit Orban mit Erdogan ja ein
Problem dass eine Talkshow für sich
beanspruchen könnte
sozusagen eine Art ausfallklappe aber
auch da ist natürlich viele hängt davon
ab wie in welcher Form dieser Krieg
ausgeht ob der einfach so aus klingt
oder ob es wirklich einen formellen
Schlussakt im Sinne eines
Waffenstillstandes gibt und wieder dann
ausschaut das sind erhebliche
Determinanten für sozusagen die
Nachkriegs Ukraine und und welche
Fürsorge Aufgaben ist dann für Sie auch
gibt und gibt es in der Ukraine Frau
Bart auch ja natürlich gibt es eine
Ermüdung von Krieg aber gibt es nach wie
vor den großen Rückhalt
es kostet was wolle wir müssen diesen
Krieg gewinnen oder gibt es auch Stimmen
die sagen wir müssen irgendeine Art
jetzt diesen Krieg beenden und dafür
auch Zugeständnisse machen nein
das kann ich so ganz kurz beantworten
diese Stimmen gibt es wenn in einer
absoluten Minderheit die Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung
möchte kämpfen nicht im Sinne weil sie
Spaß daran haben sondern weil sie müssen
weil sie bedroht werden weil sie sich
verteidigen müssen
wir oder ich spreche mit vielen Soldaten
die jetzt auch sich neu gemeldet haben
für die sogenannte Gegenoffensive
niemand von denen möchte dass niemand
von denen möchte im Schützengraben sein
ich habe höchst traumatisierte Männer
dort kennengelernt deren Leben ist
ruiniert für immer die sind psychisch so
belastet und die wollen es nicht und Sie
sagen trotzdem ich will nicht hier sein
aber ich habe keine andere Wahl weil ich
möchte meine Familie beschützen im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes und auch da
komme ich wieder zurück auf die
Verbrechen die passiert sind und die
auch immer noch passieren das ist eine
wirkliche Motivation für die Menschen
wenn sie sehen was für Kriegsverbrechen
besetzten Gebieten passieren und wir
sehen das wenn ein Gebiet von der
ukrainischen Armee zurückerobert wird
wir als Reporter gehen mittlerweile fest
davon aus dass wir Massengräber finden
und Folterkellern so systematisch ist
diese Gewalt und das merken die Menschen
natürlich in der Ukraine und deswegen
wollen sie weiterkämpfen und einen
Nebeneffekt natürlich ist auch ein
unfassbarer Hass mittlerweile gegen den
Nachbarn und das ist etwas was sich
viele Menschen noch vor über einem Jahr
nicht hätten vorstellen können weil die
Verbindungen die familiären Verbindungen
doch teilweise sehr sehr eng sind und
ich habe mehrere Menschen getroffen die
ihr den Kontakt zu ihren Brüdern zu
ihren Eltern teilweise abgebrochen haben
die in Russland leben und ihnen erzählen
dann ihr bombardiert euch selber
vielleicht eine kleine Einschränkung
dazu
ich würde auch sagen es ist eine
Minderheit in der Ukraine die sozusagen
jetzt sagt Hauptsache Frieden Hauptsache
diesen Krieg irgendwie beenden aber je
näher man der Front kommt und
die näher man dort in Städte kommt in
denen schon seit zwölf Monaten die
Menschen in ihren Kellern leben weil
diese Stadt einfach in der in der
Kampfzone ist desto mehr Menschen gerade
unter den älteren die da vor allem auch
noch geblieben sind trifft man schon die
sagen die mir ist es ehrlich gesagt
inzwischen egal wer hier an der Macht
ist Russland oder die Ukraine Hauptsache
dieser Krieg endet ich war eben im
Februar März auch in einer dieser Städte
limanen
[Musik]
das kann man schon auch nachvollziehen
bestimmt absolut
absoluten das ist doch vorher schon so
gewesen vor dem 24 februar dieses Gebiet
an der alten Frontlinie sozusagen
Menschen die seit Jahrzehnten oder seit
Jahren damit leben die wollen einfach
dass der Beschuss aufhört natürlich ein
gleichzeitig müssen wir aber verstehen
dass in diesen Regionen
die allermeisten Menschen nicht mehr da
sind also in den wirklich hart
umkämpften Städten geht man davon aus
dass vielleicht zehn Prozent der
Menschen bleiben das sind sehr häufig
ältere Menschen
häufig haben die auch keinen Kontakt
mehr sozusagen zur ausmail es gibt ganze
Städte die haben keinen Strom die haben
kein Internet kein Wasser kann
eigentlich haben die gar nichts außer
ihren Keller ein feuchtes Erdloch in dem
sie versuchen irgendwie zu überleben und
all das
prägt natürlich auch dieses Bild also es
ist ein gewisser Schlag sozusagen von
Menschen der nicht fliehen kann oder
möchte und da gibt es natürlich auch ein
geringen aber ein Prozentsatz doch an
Menschen die auch man nennt sie in der
Ukraine sozusagen die warten denn also
diejenigen die auf die russischen
Truppen warten
das ist eine absolute Minderheit aber
diese Menschen gibt es tatsächlich
schauen wir noch mal ein bisschen in die
eine mögliche Zukunft der These sie
haben ja klar gesagt wir müssen
irgendwie gucken wie wir dann auch
irgendwie auch mit Russland umgehen
können in Zukunft dass das eben auch
wichtig ist und man sieht wie viel
Fehler gemacht worden in den letzten
Jahren im Umgang mit Russland was was
können Sie sich vorstellen wie das
überhaupt gehen kann
emotional sehr schwer vorstellbar nach
einem solchen verbrecherischen Krieg der
den Putin Russland begonnen hat und
einfach wer weiß wie lange durchhält
aber natürlich weiß man wie auch immer
dieser Krieg ausgeht und ich hoffe er
geht gut aus für die Ukraine Russland
ist dann immer noch da
besonders wichtiger Teil Europas Wasser
zu großer Teil ist ein riesiges Land das
Putin ja auch zugrunde richtet aus dem
Putin jedenfalls nicht das macht was
dieses Land
möglich wäre aber er hat die
Unterstützung der Bevölkerung ja aber
das hat da müssten wir jetzt reden über
Ideologie über imperiales imperiale
Denk- und gefühlstraditionen in Russland
ich will nur sagen es ist immer noch da
und dann wird das verrückte sein dass
kann man sich jetzt nicht vorstellen wir
in Europa werden nach dem Kriegel
hoffentlich nach Putin mit Russland doch
wieder so etwas wie eine Art
Modernisierungspartnerschaft beginnen
müssen weil wir eine Interesse haben
müssen dass dies nicht ein reaktionäres
und damit immer auch gefährliches
rückständiges Land ist sondern ein Land
das sozusagen auch
technologischen wissenschaftlichen und
damit auch zivilisatorischen und
demokratischen Fortschritt erlebt und
das ist wichtig als eine Voraussetzung
für Frieden und sehen sie da jetzt
Punkte wo man damit jetzt irgendwie an
wo man ansetzen könnte während des
kriege ich nicht aber natürlich weil
alle Versuche
zivilgesellschaftliche Kontakte aufrecht
zu halten kulturelle Kontakte auf seinen
ja nicht an Europa Schaltern sondern ein
Putin und seinem regimetern aber
trotzdem ist meine Aufgabe für hinterher
also diese diese Perspektive darf man
sich nicht in dieser Brutalität des
Krieges vollständig verdunkeln lassen
inzwischen ist doch die Zahl der der
Deutschen in Russland begrenzt auf 350
sind aber auch russische
Generalkonsulate in Deutschland
schließen na gut als Antwort als Antwort
genau also ja genau im russischen Freund
telefoniert heute der gesagt hat das
natürlich eine sehr schlechte Nachricht
der ist ein großer Fan von Deutschland
dass diese ganzen Konsulate jetzt die
deutschen Konsulate schließen in
verschiedenen russischen Städten weiß
natürlich viele in Russland gibt die
sehr gerne noch entweder nach
Deutschlands gereist sind oder auch
darüber nachgedacht hat Deutschland
umzuziehen und wenn jetzt nur motiviert
das Konsulat schließt das heißt quasi
Ende der Fahnenstange weil dann müssen
die Leute nach Moskau fahren
5000 km um einen riesen zu beantragen so
dass
Putin auch gerade damit beschäftigen
diesen Maßnahmen wirklich noch
Verbindung Kappen zu Deutschland und
andere noch ein Ansatz wie man jetzt wo
man irgendwo ansetzen könnte auch noch
mal in Russland bestimmte Oppositionelle
zu stärken die ist ja eigentlich jetzt
ja auch nicht mehr gibt also die
oppositionellen die irgendwie öffentlich
aktiv waren in Russland die haben das
Land verlassen oder sie sitzen im Knast
so muss man das sagen es gibt natürlich
viele die auch in ihrem Freundeskreis
über diesen Krieg reden die sich einig
sind in der Ablehnung dieses Krieges
aber es gibt momentan Null Spielraum in
Russland das denn in diese Richtung
irgendwie politisch aktiv zu werden
wenn wer was denken Sie wie lange der
Westen mit die Unterstützung durchhält
und wie wichtig ist dass wenn wir jetzt
noch mal versuchen zu gucken also wenn
wir jetzt über die Kampfjets reden all
diese Diskussion wo sagen sie wenn wenn
das so weitergeht mit der Unterstützung
ist das ein wirklich militärischen
Möglichkeit diesen Krieg doch innerhalb
von einem Jahr oder irgendwie was ist da
ihre Zeit Horizont zu beenden
Sache also wir haben die Ressourcen wir
haben das Geld wir haben die Technik wir
haben die die Ingenieure
umrüstungsgüter bereitzustellen
umrüstungswirtschaftlich wenn wir
sozusagen dass das Geld das wir haben
auch zu einem höheren geraden
militarisieren so böses klingt aber das
ist das wo er oder Russland den Vorteil
hatten das ist keine Überläufe
überlegene Wirtschaft ist kein
überlegener Technikraum es ist kein
überlegene forschungsmacht aber der
militarisierungsgrad der Gesellschaft
der Wissen der Wissenschaft der der
Wirtschaft ist in Russland einfach höher
und das ist der Vorteil auf dem Putin
spielt das ist bei uns willensfrage
eventuell verändern mit einem anderen
Präsidenten
ich ich hoffe dass es sich nach dem
Krieg oder nach Putin irgendwann ändert
in Russland sind natürlich lange keine
Garantie und wir haben auch das müssen
wir uns mal auch einräumen eigentlich
keine stell Schrauben und keinen
Einfluss darauf das ist eine eine Sache
die in Russland die russische
Gesellschaft mit sich selber ausmachen
wird müssen ohne ohne unser Zutun oder
zumindest und unser Zutun in einem einen
nennenswerten Einflussbereich
aber für die Dauer dieses Krieges
ist die Lage so wie sie ist nur wie
gesagt das ist im Westen willensfrage
und es sollte ich meine es ist mit
dieser Krieg aus geht bestimmt unsere
sicherheitsordnung bestimmt auch das
sicher nicht nur das subjektive
Sicherheitsgefühl sondern auch die
Objektive Sicherheitslage in der unsere
Kinder groß werden das heißt wir sollten
aus eigenem Interesse das ist jetzt
sozusagen nicht nur humanitäre sozusagen
kommunitäre Hilfe für die Ukraine
sondern nur eigenes Interesse dass ich
hier Angriffskrieg Annexion unvollkommen
gewaltsame unvollkommen nicht lohnt und
nicht auszahlt das sind wir eigentlich
unsere ganzen nächsten europäischen
Generation entschuldigen Sie wie lange
diese die Unterstützung auch in
Deutschland von den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern bleibt diesen Krieg der Ukraine
weiterzuhelfen darüber gibt es ja
durchaus Diskussion sie ist noch groß in
Deutschland aber es gibt einen nicht
geringen Teil sogar eher in
Ostdeutschland die
emotional und politisch anders ticken
das ist das ist ein Mischung von Motiven
die schwer zu erklären ist auch mir als
DDR Bürger oder
man will ich will nur sagen noch mal
daran erinnern dass das gefährliche
Russlands besteht darin an dem
Missverhältnis zwischen der
militärischen Stärke einer militäre
Wirtschaft und der sonstigen Schwäche
der wissenschaftlichen technologischen
zivilisatorischen Schwäche das macht das
Land gefährlich das war schon bei der
Sowjetunion ein Teil der Gefahr die
davon ausgehen und deswegen muss unser
Interesse sein dieses Land nach einem
Krieg zu Ende wirklich beim Weg in die
Moderne zu helfen
vielen Dank Herr Thierse Herr Gartmann
Frau Bart und Herr Kresse für die
Diskussion hier wird sicherlich nicht
die letzte Diskussion über diesen
furchtbaren Krieg gewesen sein vielen
Dank für Ihr Interesse das war die
Phönix und in dieser Woche machen sie es
gut bis dann
[Musik]